what movie do you look back at and say
with just a twinge of
regret i wish i'd made that you mean
like a movie that i passed on
no movie that's out now that someone
else made is there one that you go
oh i wish i'd made that that's like the
most perfect film
oh man i don't really feel like
i don't feel that sensation when i look
at other people's films i look at other
people's films and i'm impressed with
them
legitimately but i don't necessarily
want to be that person or wish i was
that person or did that film
because they they did it their way and i
could never have achieved what they
had done because i would do it my way in
a different way but the raid 2
the most recent film that i saw that i
was just like
i have a lot of work to do as a
filmmaker this movie is so well done
and the action is just so perfect and
the cinematography is incredible
and the pacing is just really ballsy and
and
i have a lot of respect for that
filmmaker so he did a great job on that
film and
you know i hope he does a lot more so
that's one of those films where i'm like
man i have like
a motivation to continue getting better
because that's
incredible you know and uh
i'm not threatened by that or anything i
just i find it exciting that there's
other people out there that make movies
that are
good enough that i can feel that way
about it
you